[Music]
constellation starship
frontier we have you on scanners
we still go
they say the wonder is not that the
field of stars
is so vast but that we have measured it
you're part of constellation now part of
our family what you found
it's the key to unlocking everything
[Music]
we've come to the beginning of
humanity's final journey
prepare for departure
[Music]
that's why we're here
to discover what's out there
[Music]
attention all squads the russian troops
are falling back
do whatever you can to secure the sector
[Applause]
we push them back but not far enough do
not let them regroup
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
we need to get away from
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a new day is upon us a new
generation built to fight
together we are unstoppable
are you ready
[Music]
[Music]
killing
[Music]
hello let's do some damage
return it to base
ordinance drop inbound
the flag is ours
please call us at your earliest
convenience
now show me what you can do
these things where do they come from
from all of us from what we do to him
can you stop it i don't know
but he's my brother and i would die for
him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
i recognize that voice let me ask you a
question
when i am dead and yara is burning
what exactly is your plan hold hands
sing songs around the fire sure
i know just this song
[Music]
for the right job
keep talking as a stealth operation
i got you covered
[Music]
taking out a high value target i have
just what you need
you want to blow [ __ ] up juan cortese at
your service
[Music]
everyone got us all that [ __ ] what
wait a second who brought the rooster
hey whatever you need to get the job
done danny
[Music]
next time i see you i want to play with
that crazy backpack
[Music]
so do i
[Applause]
evil has survived
a dark figure wanders in the east
[Music]
he must be stopped
at all costs
fear me
you're true
this may be our darkest hour
but it will be your greatest moment
[Music]
oh
an eel wind blows from beyond the
horizon
a new danger is coming on the tides
and the one who might stop this ruin
trapped for all forever in the sea of
the damned
now to save the pirate life
you must start by saving
didn't realize we had company
captain jack sparrow
but i suspect you already knew that
because of the treasure jack storm a
darkness
followed in here and if it's not stopped
this world will sink into shadow
this sea holds many secrets
ah a new body unlocks all i can do is
sure you know
from what i hear of this so-called sea
of thieves
is nothing but kurt cruz blood versus
mermaids a legion of dead
angry pirates oh yes
and now one davy jones
[Music]
well i believe that now is the perfect
time to use these cannons
a world without the eternal face
is a world that refuses to face the
truth
nothing lasts forever destroy that
i don't suppose by chance there's a
second one of those
the sea of thieves i bring me that
horizon
luck experience
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
dude
i
foreign
foreign
stalker
we begin by hearing an old wise sounding
voice
when we see a quiet peaceful setting
this will make our game seem big and
important
now something must break the serenity
will this creature be in the game
no say goodbye to it forever
suddenly and for no reason people
running these pointless slow motion
shots
make everything seem cool and should
bolster pre-sale numbers
that war sound can mean only one thing
we must gaze over an epic shot of a
world
and there should be lens flares
now we see our hero
but only the silhouette because the
developers haven't finished the design
paul finished the story or finished any
game play
that's actually ready to show in fact
the only thing
they have finished
is the title
[Music]
[Music]
roof
[Applause]
tell me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me what you want right now
let everybody talk right now tell me
what you want right now
you can get it yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
save oh tear drops
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
always
hello forza fans the wait is finally
over
all the speculation finally came to an
end yesterday at the xbox and bethesda
game showcase
when playground games announced forza
horizon
5. that's right the horizon festival is
headed to beautiful diverse mexico for
the fifth title
in the series you'll get to explore an
epic ever-evolving
vibrant open-world landscape full of
cacti volcanoes
tropical storms dust storms and hundreds
of the world's greatest cars
voice horizon 5 is available on november
9th and you can play it
day one on xbox game pass your ultimate
horizon adventure awaits
so let's go i'm today i'm live with
playground games to talk about
yesterday's forza horizon
5 announcement then we're going to be
taking a closer look
at breathtaking open world festival
location mexico
after that we're going to talk about the
artistic detail that went into
recreating the country's
unique landscapes we'll also get the
scoop on some of the game's
new features and before we wrap the show
we're happy to answer some questions so
pop them into chat as long as we go
and we'll see if we can get round to a
few of them and beside me today
are two of the members responsible
playground games creative director
mike brown and chris is a creative
director of playground games not that
he's actually the associate art director
connor cross hello both how are you
hey charlie yeah i bet you
are very exciting how are you connor
brilliant to be here yeah it's been a
big old 24 hours for you both right
absolutely yeah it's been yeah barely
slept to be honest
yeah that was going to be one of my
questions how do you sleep after
something like that
um yeah i think i was up at about half
one last night yeah
in the thoughts of discord chatting at
the fans just making sure it all happens
what was the vibes like yesterday when
when the show was on obviously you knew
it was coming up did
like did you know when it was going to
be on in the show
you just have to it's actually super
secretive
oh we won't go down that route then very
very few people
know the whole show um you but you
basically know your bits and you
you get feedback on on your bits we're
doing different proposals about what we
want to include in it but
um yeah you don't know what anyone else
is doing and they'll kind of say things
like oh
it works really well in the context of
where it is okay games around you you're
like
okay okay is there anything we should
change to make it better
no don't worry about anybody else's okay
and then it appeared and then that was
it
the game was out in the world so tell us
more about forza horizon 5 then what is
it
what are we expecting here yeah it's the
the biggest it's the most diverse it's
the most fun
uh horizon yeah it's the biggest open
world we've ever built
it's got an incredible new suite of
social features which just make it such
a
fun engaging and compelling social
experience to hang out with your friends
and yeah this couldn't be more exciting
to share with the world yesterday i
can't wait to unpick it and connor we're
going to come to you first actually
because
one of the things that everyone on
social media was talking about yesterday
is about how phenomenal forza horizon 5
looks with some of them even saying it's
the greatest looking game
of all time and as the art director how
does that feel everyone's saying these
lovely things about what you've been
doing
oh great
um yeah it's uh you know we've got such
a great team here at playground that you
know really
you know know their stuff and you know
and
we've got we're working on mexico you
know it's mexico and just looking at all
the eco types that we're working on
every single one is so beautiful that
you know when when you pull that
together
you know make such a as mike said
diverse but absolutely breathtaking
you know set of visuals there that you
know i can't wait to show more of yeah
and it's sort of one of those things
where it's mexico like it was going to
be a really easy job to make it look
beautiful
right so yeah definitely absolutely yeah
we're going to unpick more of that but
let's have a look at some of the
excitement you guys shared on social
media
yesterday with our first tweet here
being from roby4tv who was
sort of just excited that it was true um
what's
what's that like what's the reaction
that you guys have seen of people
finally getting relieved that
it's happening it's here and it's also
only in a few months as well
yeah i mean even though we've obviously
we
we play the game the game's a lot of fun
we think it looks great but i can't tell
you how
what the anxiety is like going into that
show and not knowing how people are
gonna react to it
um and also not knowing like is anybody
else doing an open world game in mexico
they could be
yeah fair dudes you never really know do
you um so it is
yeah the anxiety levels are crazy but as
soon as it happened and you just my
twitter feed
fills up my phone nearly exploded i sent
you a text you didn't get back to me for
hours
so we've got another tweet here from
slap train it says holy forts horizon
five
let's go so many new things they're r d
we're going to talk about some of them
today
um but yeah i mean there's there's a lot
of things to come right forward five is
huge as you've already said
oh yes yeah yeah oh yes lovely
up next we've got confucius max who says
five is in mexico
yeah i need that asap so we're gonna
talk about this in a moment actually but
are you it seems like a lot the
excitement has actually been because
it's mexico
is that something you're really really
happy that you've seen fans have really
caught on to not the fact that it's
another game but that it's mexico
totally yeah it's it's one because we've
throughout the development of horizon 5
we've been
really really getting deep into mexico
and really like kind of falling in love
with that country
and it's just like it's a job right
sorry the perk of the job
it's just so exciting to see other
people like feel that love as well as
soon as they've seen it
i think everybody that certainly every
reaction i saw was like super pumped i
thought it looked great
and it's just really reassuring to know
that other people love mexico as much as
which is we do brilliant lovely and our
last tweet
is from hugo who says i'll read the
bottom one
the most beautiful graphics ever in the
history of the gaming
world i'm guessing you both agree all
right you have to right conor otherwise
there's a lot of question marks on you
really
i'm not yes no i completely agree the
trailer was absolutely stunning and
what a perfect time why don't we have a
look at the trailer we've all been
talking about
here is the force horizon 5 announcement
trailer
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
tell me what you want and i'll tell you
what i'm gonna do i'm not giving up come
on we got nothing left to lose
[Music]
like a hurricane for electricity
[Music]
let everybody talk right now tell me
what you want right now
you could get it yeah
[Music]
you can get it
at day one with xbox game pass
so obviously the reveal was absolutely
awesome the room i was in alone with
screams
jaws hitting the floor a bit of
everything but i think this clip
actually from forza streamer ash
really kind of sums up how we all feel
should we take a look
it has to be oh my god
yes it is
oh my god oh my god
oh my god
[Laughter]
hi thank you that was
so fun to watch the the hype is so so
real
uh mike we're gonna go to you first so
fans have been hoping for a new horizon
game and the fact that it's imminent is
even better
uh the big question really is and we
picked a little bit on it before but
why mexico why are we going to mexico
yeah so
um it's it's the question that um we
deliberate on the most like what
what location is the horizon fest we're
going to go to for each game
we start thinking about it right at the
start of development of a new horizon
title and we spend a really long time
making that call
oh i can imagine it's not the quickest
decision you'll ever make really
well there's just it has all these kind
of trickle-down effects for the rest of
the game like
the cars that you'll pick the type of
racing that you do the type of music
that you go with
so it has really far-reaching
ramifications so you need to make sure
you make the absolute right decision
right from the start we knew that we
wanted to make the biggest horizon ever
and you don't get that far down that
path before you realize there's no point
making the biggest
ever unless it's also the most diverse
because otherwise you're just
adding more of the same mexico
is a country which is almost like the
whole world in one country it's got
snowy mountains
epic canyons beautiful historic cities
stunning coastlines
jungles rolling hills farmland
multiple different types of desert
[Laughter]
it's just it's just it just has
everything and then you add on top of
that the fact that it has this culture
that's known and loved
all around the world the art the music
the people um
there couldn't be a more exciting option
for the horizon festival than mexico
yeah i can't just the image of like cars
bombing around it as well and
you saw how diverse it was from the
trailer so we're going to move over into
the art stuff now and
we saw some game footage from the demo
during the xbox and bethesda showcase
yesterday so i want to get into some of
that and talk about
how incredibly good it looks so connor
from your point of view what
improvements do we see from
ray tracing in forts horizon five so we
have ray tracing in forza vista
and ray tracing is is basically the the
closest or the next step to
complete photo realism um it's a way
which light's calculated
and reflections are calculated that is
pretty much
you might as well be there looking at it
um you know if you look you look there
you can see the
you know the thin as the project one
even the letters reflected perfectly the
same
resolution and everything and so yeah
it's uh you know
i can't wait for everyone to go check
out all their favorite cars and their
setups in ray tracing it's gonna be
amazing and having spent time talking to
some of the community that takes so many
pictures
in horizon it feels like that is gonna
be a mode for them
to really dive into but also on the
trailer you mentioned how diverse is we
saw a rainforest that was in there as
well
um and i don't know if it's the uk
weather at the moment being so hot but
you can actually
feel the humidity in that clip how did
how did you do that
um so you know as with everything we
looked at tons and tons of reference
and you know we really want to be as
true to that place as possible to make
it feel like you're really there
um and you know you're absolutely
correct it's super humid
and the way we did that is by
introducing lots of volumetric light
which is a great big volume of basically
particles that light scatters through
and
um reacts in the way that you know humid
and you know
fog and all that stuff works so it
allows you to have all these glorious
god rays from all the sun coming through
and i love that
god ray that's how cool that does um
and you know you know all the light
diffusion to give it more technical um
you know it's close to um you know how
that would work in real life as well
that was one of the things i really
enjoyed from the trailer actually was
that um
you would you would see an image that
looked like it was just a picture
but then you would actually sort of like
cheekily the gameplay would then come in
off the corner of it and it was just
this like
clout image of yeah the game actually
looks this good but i'm gonna test you
now actually connor
um so of all of the beautiful uh
greenery that we do see in the game
i want to ask you if you've done your
research how many needles are there
actually on a cactus on the on the choya
cactus
um so i know the actual number okay um
do you know it mike
i i have been told the number i don't
know if i can recall it right now
okay yeah um so i'm not going to give
the actual number out because there's
probably
bragging rights on on twitter or
something but the one person that does
actually go into someone will do it
after this now yeah
uh but do you want to take a stab do you
want to take a guess i mean
i i absolutely have no clue but a number
that feels big to be able to set a
couple hundred maybe a thousand at a
push or something
that's a lot it i mean i was uh you know
my immediate action when i was you know
told the exact number from from our
great foliage team was
no no no chance right um but you know
there
is 42 000 and that give or take
wow each of those choice cactus yeah
they are all of each choice itself is
unique so it's not not exactly 4000
wow okay and i mean talking about cactus
and looking at this clip here
the desert significantly greener than at
least what i thought it was going to be
is this a feature of mexico that you've
brought into the game definitely um like
like i've said we tried to be
as true and honest to the location as
possible um
we've got several different deserts uh
for all of you desert
um desert nuts out there um so we've got
there's got the community uh we've got
you know your classic
uh sand uni desert um and then we've got
the you know the baja type desert you've
seen there that
is it's lush we actually call it the
living desert in game
and what you're looking at there is
actually in the wet season which is
summer
um where you know everything's in full
bloom you get the pink uh pink flowers
come out the sand verbana all the um
and celia flowers are out as well yeah
it's uh you know
it's it's great because it's you know
everyone's everyone's
preconceived idea of a desert it's just
rolling sand and yeah
sand dunes and it's just dismal and
you're looking for water everywhere you
go but that's not what that looks like
wow there's there's you know you can
find little oasis hidden around here
with palm trees and
you know it's um yeah there's there's
absolute ton of it to go and explore as
well so
lovely now obviously i know what
photogrammetry is but for anyone
listening
obviously but for anyone listening at
home who may not have heard that term
yet could you let us know what that is
and how it comes into play unfortunately
sure so so photogrammetry is is
basically the process
of taking hundreds or if not thousands
of photos
of a thing you want to recreate from
every single angle um
and then we've actually compiled all of
that in some software and and just put
it in the game
and we do that for a lot of things so
you know
like all these rocks here yeah that bit
there that was the bit i was talking
about
ridiculous scenes wow we do yeah we do
it for everything all the way down to
roads
um just to try and capture it as
honestly and as authentic as it was when
you found it yeah
yeah it's it's gorgeous i do have to ask
though
i know you guys take your research very
seriously so
uh who had to climb up the volcano to
get the data on that one
so we've uh we've got a a brilliant team
of
photographers actually um and we even um
you know got some help from some mexican
photographers as well but lovely it took
that team to some
great spots and he provided you know
what what would be the best
you know the best most honest
representation of the area and um
you know they do all the photogrammetry
they take all the stuff back they
distribute the reference to the team
they're very fit now yeah i bet they are
yeah
um yeah yeah lovely i mean we're looking
at the city here as well um is it
this sounds really silly is it actually
that colorful it looks incredible i've
never been there but would you look at
that
it definitely is it definitely is lovely
and like you know we've
so we've sampled all of the color from
um
from real life locations as well but uh
one of the other other cities we've got
in in the game is guanajato
um and we've done exactly the same thing
there where we've sampled every single
color
they've even got like beautiful red
terracotta roofs that you can see
gorgeous
um there is a uh there's a fun little
tidbit
oh i love a fun fact that might be true
yes so yeah
one of the one of our team came back and
said hey um when we're looking at these
buildings they're actually all slightly
you know they are slightly different
colors but the law
apparently might even be a rule don't
quote me on it is that
you can paint your house whatever color
you want as long as it's not the same as
your neighbor's house
oh i love that so that's resulted in
some you know really
brilliant pinks and such a diverse city
as well and just look so gorgeous to
drive that makes me think of bala mori
i won't lie but a bit nicer than that
though anyway you sold me
and i now do need to go to mexico but
before i get my ticket
uh let's get uh talking about some of
the new features that we mentioned were
coming up
so what is forza link that's the first
one i'm going to talk about what is it
and how does it work
sure yeah so uh thoughts link is a new
ai assistant that tracks the
current status of you and everybody else
in the world as well as your current
progress like through the campaign and
my festival playlist activities um and
the job of thought to link is to try and
remove any friction and barriers between
you joining up and playing with other
people that you might meet online
um so it'll track the things i like to
do and it'll track things i have and
haven't done
and it might do the same for you as well
and if it knows for example that we
both love to do the trial but we haven't
yet done it this week okay then it might
prompt me to go hey charlie do you want
to come and do the trial
and then you'd go yeah cool and then it
just groups us together uh starts
matchmaking and then we go through that
activity wow okay
um it yeah in that scenario we might not
know each other we might not have
microphones but the games kind of try
and
try and just join the dots between
people and help them make a bit more
social exactly oh i love
it and one of the other things i loved
as well actually is we saw in the
trailer
pinatas and that's in the horizon arcade
so can you give us the lowdown on what
the arcade is
yeah so the arcade is a a suite
of really really fun engaging mini games
you'll all play in a
collaborative or cooperative way and
they're a bit there are public events so
they spawn in the world a little bit
like you might have seen in destiny
um you drive up to them there's there's
no loading screens no menus you just get
automatically signed up by being in the
area yeah grouped up with some of the
players
and then you all work together to try
and overcome whatever the challenge may
be
and this in this one you've got to try
and smash as many pinatas as you can but
there's
there's a load of other different game
modes in there as well one of my
favorites is called mini missions
which is a little bit like simon says so
just throws up a like a little challenge
on screen which might say like jump over
another car
and then you've got to try and work
together with other players there to try
and get get your cars lined up so that
you can jump over them and that only
lasts for a few seconds
another challenge oh i can't wait to
play that one there was another one i
saw in the trailer as well
which was like you were it's like big
bowling alley and you were like booping
into the sky of speakers is that
another one of those um so that's not
part of the horizon arcade this
is what somebody has created within
event lab so in this example
obviously somebody on our team has put
this together um but this is
this is the kind of thing that players
will be able to create themselves with
event lab so someone's gone through
placed all of the things that we can see
here including those bowling pins
and then they set up a set of rules so
there's
a bunch of rules that'll be going on to
make this game mode work but some of the
ones that
i'll call out are so each time you hit
one of those pins
they've set up a rule that adds 5 000
points to your team's
score it didn't have to be a team-based
game they could have had it be a
free-for-all or
a team versus team game mode where
you're all
fighting against each other trying to
smash as many pins as you can um
it's actually based on the development
tools that we use as a design team
yeah so it's a it is a really really
powerful tool set um
and one that i really can't wait to see
what people create with i could see me
spending
a lot of time in that especially
streaming with like getting a big convoy
together and hanging out and having fun
that looks like
a hundred percent my cup of tea and
there's it's all incredible and there's
so much to look forward to
um and i'm saying this very personally
but you guys do continue to not only
improve upon this amazing series with
each new title but actually come up with
new fact
new ways for fans to actually play the
game as well so
um we know chat has been really excited
about forza horizon 5. so are you guys
ready
for some questions from them
i guess so you've kind of like made that
sound kind of scary though yeah
you're on the hot seat okay so first
question
is from cockney chalmer by the way hello
county chalmer thank you for joining us
uh
can we have some convertibles please
yes yeah there you go signed off sorted
yeah yeah there will be a few
convertibles in the game at launch
you'll be able to just
click take the roof down click the stick
oh yeah
stick the radio on drive around the
desert sorted left stick in
and uh i think it's left stick one of
the sticks
one of those i think you're right i
think it's more related to come on which
stick it is
yeah and then that's all it takes
perfect now we touched on this very very
loosely already but uh lone hermit crab
asks will there be a big city and not
just small
towns you mentioned that there were a
couple already um when you spoke before
connor
so we've you know mexico has got
arguably one of the most beautiful
cities ever and that's guanajuato and
it's
huge um and with that um
it's kind of two cities in one and it's
got a like a aqueduct system underneath
um
so you've got all this bright colorful
you know beautiful architecture up top
and then it's like
you know really gnarly tiny little you
know
roads that all in tunnels underneath
that you can drift in and around
god that sounds incredible yeah it's
it's weird how
as as we're building horizon games you
find that if
if the city existed before cars it tends
to be really really good for driving
modern cities are all grid-based right
which yeah don't make for the best
driving experience whereas uh
guanajuato's
every road is curving banking dipping
underneath another road
it's just like it's got this incredible
organic road network which just
i mean if you're designing it from
scratch just out of your imagination
you probably wouldn't come up with a
city that was that sounds brilliant that
sounds really really fun yeah
um ray has also in chat uh has asked
every horizon game has incorporated
parts of the car culture present in its
irl setting
what elements of mexican car culture are
you bringing to horizon five
great question it is a great question
we're not actually in a position to talk
about
uh cars too much at the moment because
we're still uh landing the final car
list
um but i will say that yeah it's a thing
that we really take pride in uh
in all of our games we really want to
capture that local car culture
and that's absolutely true for mexico as
well i think i'm gonna
um hold off on this one actually and say
we'll close closer to launch we'll
really go deep on this but
just for now we'll we'll uh no i know
that i mean simply knowing that you
mentioned before the like the the
culture of mexico as a whole
is is very much a character in the game
so hearing more about that is obviously
ideal
uh danny88 has asked a question very
close to my heart
is there a drag race in the game
there are several uh several game yeah
yeah
there is one that runs through the main
festival site as well which is
especially cool
oh yeah i mean is that i really know how
to ask this but like how do you
what is the festival site is it still
the sort of area that has like a couple
cool races in or is there
is it still just like a i don't even
know what i'm trying to say i'm just
excited i want to talk about horizon
festival you know i can probably talk
about the festival
um so surprise
there's going to be more than one oh but
the main festival site which is going to
be horizon mexico okay
um is is built on a really old race
track
so there's there is an awesome race
track off to the side of it and it's
also built on
a old airstrip as well the middle desert
um you know you've got all your typical
festival stuff going on
uh with a badass drag strip right in the
middle of it and uh racetrack off the
side as well
gorgeous i love it i cannot wait to see
it uh on off
ps chat uh says do we know if the
weather changes
anybody know i think with the two people
here who might know can you confirm if
the weather changes
the weather does change and it is local
as well this time
oh so you can be at one side of the map
and you can see a storm kicking off and
you can drive all the way over there you
could do storm chasing yeah you can do
that
um you can i mean we've even got
sandstorm so that's a tropical you can
do tropical storm
so you can do it you can drive into a
tropical storm um
and you know you can go inside that
thing and there'll be loads of you know
leaves flying off trees and everything
going crazy and then you could probably
leave that and see a sandstorm on the
other side of the map
and go drive straight into that thing as
well wow it's one of the really uh
interesting things about about mexico
and the way it presents challenges for
us with seasonality
is that because a massive country has
really huge elevation changes
you find that you can almost have
different climates at the same time yeah
yeah
in the same season imagine um so in in
winter which is the dry season
on top of the volcano it's covered in
snow you can get blizzards oh wow um but
it's the dry season so you go into the
down to the beach
it's blazing hot so you can actually
be in a blizzard drive down the side of
the volcano arrive at the coast
and it'd be enemy blazing hot yeah
sunburn yeah
um dj customs in chat less a question
just says can't wait to drift tap
cactus i mean fair dues i mean
one of the things i didn't want to know
is that i mean again don't comment on
this if you can't but one of the things
i
suffer with hugely in horizon is hitting
all the trees
so will the cactuses move out the way
when i hit them or are there some rigid
ones in there you can uh you can smash
all the cactus
you can drift tap as many as you want
and there are hundreds i'm afraid to
actually side swipe if it smashes
drift hack is only for immovable objects
there you go you need to get technical
sorry but now you know and now we all
know
green machines asked will there be any
animals and also second question will
there be seasons we've talked a little
bit about the seasons already
um so yes there will be animals and we
have
we saw flamingos in the uh are these
smart animals
by the way in the way that the sheep
moved out the way will the flamingos
move
actually yeah a smarter this time around
so
that sounds like a challenge that does
so we've got wild dogs um you know
anyone who's been to mexico will know
there's you know wild dogs
that you can see everywhere and now
they'll be you know sleeping on porches
or sleeping out
you know around and you can rudely
disturb them
around your heart's content we've got
we've got donkeys
uh goats flamingos as mike said that
people have seen in the
in the gameplay reveal um some birds
parrots that sort of stuff
larvae chrome finance says again not
really a question just we want
long highways like autobahn is that
something that's featured in the mexican
yeah yeah it's i say it's the uh it's
the largest map
ever and it does have a big highway that
runs kind of
corner to corner so probably wow i
haven't measured it but i imagine it
must be the longest
um it's got to be yeah it's gonna be the
longest time we've ever had yeah
in comparison to an english motorway
that feels like it stretches for you
[Applause]
yes yes perfect and last but not least
uh wolfgang 302 asks what is new in
customization
oh wow wolfgang that is uh that there's
a big answer for that one that's a big
old question yeah there's
no no doubt we'll uh certainly forget
some of the options here so for car
customization
um there are over 100 new rims over 100
new uh
visual upgrade parts thousands of
performance upgrades
um you can also paint your brake
calipers which
is a thing that people have been
clamoring for for a number of years
and i did say once we'll add that to
thoughts horizon 4 and then proceed to
not add it for
at all so but this time it exists oh
yeah
this time it's real i've promised it
after we've made it rather than before
[Laughter]
we've also had a ton of character
customization options so um you can
customize your hair hair style hair
color you can choose prosthetic limbs
you can
set your pronoun you can choose your
voice uh so there's much more options
when you're customizing how you appear
in the game
as well as how your car appears i made
my character day one i don't know if you
know this i made my character day one
with the same crown and like the duck
boots and i haven't changed her since
and she has like that i think it's like
the pulp fiction
emote and i just thought she was perfect
as she was i'm not touched over so i
love that you can have all of these like
new elements
to make the real you on day one i just
think it's superb
great to see you really engaged with
that feature oh yeah no i honestly i
just found the bits i wanted day one and
i was like you know what that's banging
that's exactly how i want my character
look so
you know maybe i have to get a bit
deeper on this one but that's everything
that's everything we have time for today
lads thank you so much for joining me uh
i'm obviously and also on behalf of
everyone watching in chat really looking
forward to hearing more
about votes horizon 5 in the coming
months as i said we are at the end of
the show
so it's time to say goodbye and there's
been so much exciting news in just 24
hours that i
physically cannot handle it any longer
uh one more time for those in the back
or if you missed it right the beginning
of the stream forza horizon 5
will be available on november 9th on
xbox series x and s
xbox one windows 10 pc and steam you can
also play it
day one on xbox game pass and xbox game
pass subscribers can get early access
on november 5th with the premium add-ons
bundle
and if you're an eager beaver you can
even pre-install the game
today right now thank you so much for
watching everyone stay tuned to the
forza channels for franchise updates and
more thoughts horizon 5 news
soon adios everyone
[Music]
[Music]
tell
left to me
[Music]
[Music]
like a hurricane
[Music]
[Music]
you can get it play it day one with xbox
game pass
let it go it go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you